we tamper
with the fabric of reality
what's happening starting to come
through and i can't stop him
i can't believe i'm in the saints i'm
saying it's horum
neither can
i hi everyone i am tom holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and i am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new adventure in spider-man no way
home i know people say this a lot but i
mean it when i say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before i'm talking about
pumpkin bombs
sandstorm
the multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but i promise
not like this and not together also
peter parker is finally heading off to
college and the word is out so yeah
everyone knows that he is spider-man
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they
and get ready to see one of the most
ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of possibilities spiderman is
in fact peter parker
my entire life got screwed up
could you make it so that mysterio never
revealed my identity you ready
what just happened
when i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors looks like we got
competition
from every universe
i promise i'll fix this exclusively at
movie theaters december 17th rated pg-13
where are we going i don't know your
house no i don't kill you i thought you
said your dad really liked me no well
not anymore
hello peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get through this
we're gonna get done together
december 17th
you